so Sports Illustrated I think you guys
are gonna like this one a new study by
the Department of Sociology at the
University of Louisville asked where all
the women in Sports Illustrated and
researchers found that out of 716 Sports
Illustrated issues published between
2000 and 2011 only 35 of them had covers
that featured female athletes and then
out of those 35 only 18 which came down
to 2.5% featured a female as the primary
or sole image and this I think brings a
bikini well this does not include the
swimsuit issue
so that would bump the number to like so
is there any surprise here that Sports
Illustrated is not featuring female
athletes the way that we might like it
to all be equal yeah I mean I would love
to get angry at this story but you can't
get angry it's not Sports Illustrated
it's the consumer right consumers don't
really care about someone from the WNBA
you know they they want to see a woman a
sexy woman in a bikini or maybe some
dude that they idolize playing some sort
of sport that they like and by Sports
Illustrated anymore like not to put them
down but who goes out and buys a Sports
Illustrated magazine like Matt the
magazine industry is in a lot of trouble
as it is and what they put on their
cover reflects what the consumer wants
and I think that's what we should really
focus on yeah well I don't know if the
consumer drives the magazine or the
magazines tell people who they should be
interested in because there's a
wonderful career going on that said I
mean when you say the WNBA that said
welcome to earth I mean that's pretty
much the percentage of women featured in
everything people say why aren't there
more female comics my line used to be
they strangled them at birth but really
why aren't there more female anything we
got in late because we weren't allowed
in and it takes a long time to get far
enough to be you know equal doctors
equal lawyers equal this equal that you
know it's a lot of it's hundreds of
years of catching up in professions and
you're just that's the reflection of the
society men running
they're gonna they want to see men it's
men running it for the most part okay so
that's why are they know naked men in
the movies they think women don't want
to see them yes we do but they don't do
things they don't want the guy in the
movies to take out more that will beat
them take out just enough to beat them
or they don't want the guy that's
sitting there going or that guy's kind
of sexy because then it could really but
you know yeah crumple Society yes but
the thing of course and it would you
certainly impact my marriage as a man
saw another man naked by done by yeah
the thing is it's that it's that um you
know they did a study and women do want
to see naked men in movies but the guys
making movies won't put them in because
they're men who don't you know I'm so
tired of saying just married of just
women just and here's that shot because
we have to put that shot and for no
reason
the woman's opening a can of baked beans
why is she topless I mean does she
really she's opening can of beans she's
you know turning on the oven and for
some reason she forgot her shirt you
know please I know women react
differently to nudity though like I
don't like if I see a naked guy if I
just see someone's like flaccid penis I
don't think like oh god I gotta have
there's your there's your problem right
there honey you have to you have to join
in Marshall you know in one of the
scenes in Forgetting Sarah Marshall
there was a flaccid penis and this
started out with sports really shame
your bus
sorry all of it put the parley back in
the concrete
so Sports Illustrated ain't no it's like
it's like what was his name that
football player or the flaccid penis
Johnson Roethlisberger yes I remembered
okay
when Roethlisberger was sending out his
his philosophy work for Anthony Weiner
he's getting back into politics although
Clinton won't back him because it's too
PETA see it's Joey can get over Camus
did politics there's a limit the women
in these cases were not turned on by it
so I think that's the reason why you
don't see like nude men in movies as
often as you seem like we need some
lovely male bodies and movies and some
swell pushes even on TV and I think it
should be a little more equal just so
you're not teaching young men growing up
that women are always the objectified
object that it's always you know we're
always kind of on the bottom we're
always on the needy end we're always on
the part that's weak and and manipulable
I think it's just important to have you
know a little more parity right but in a
weird way don't you think Sports
Illustrated not putting women on is
actually doing that you're saying though
in a bizarre way because you and I
probably buy it more if they were more
interesting women featured you know
there's you know buy it no put it on the
newsstand at least someone would have a
ninja what do you think it's okay that
guys happen to like male sports more I
don't know many guys I don't know many
guys are like the WNBA I just don't know
many girls that do either but well
that's tied to and I I don't think
that's fair I think they get short
shrift and I think first of all they
also play basketball the way basketball
began when men plated which is scrappy
little basketball instead of all these
you know science there's but now it's
Giants dunking at the rim and it's kind
of like home run baseball it used to be
a scrappy little game they said you know
baseball it's not a bad pun baseball is
a game of inches and you you worked your
way you manufactured ruins it was much
more exciting than the home run in the
early days when Babe Ruth hit all those
home runs the first year they had a have
a press conference and apologize to the
fans that he hit that he had a prime
not to hit the home runs next year
people hated it the game was like boring
which is ironic because now the phrases
chicks dig the long ball well but
without steroids there isn't much long
ball in baseball anymore so what's the
difference but the WNBA plays basketball
the way it began with men and it's a
much more exciting game to watch and I
think if if Sports Illustrated rope like
that and engaged more people men might
is that just this females view of it
because I can watch basketball yeah do
you like any female athletics no where'd
you I don't like athletics period equal
opportunity yeah no interested in male
sports female sports none of it I just
I've never been it's done a ton of
play-by-play for baseball over the years
I mean I am just the baseball queen you
know queen baseball and animal rescue
and I love you know male sports and I
don't know I don't think there should be
a female pitcher in there unless well
I've seen some female underhand pitchers
that pitch at 105 you know miles an hour
distantly and I watched one's a
strikeout gosh Wade Boggs and he was so
angry that he took the next batter spot
in the next batter spot you were doing a
charity game she had to strike him out
for three batters because he wouldn't he
refused to let a woman strike him out
and in the end they just made him sit
down so it would kind of be kind of
great if they did let a woman you know
pitch but I guess underhand and pitch in
the big leagues
yeah and Wade Boggs did not strike out a
lot so he sure didn't say you know she
was so you know she was yeah that's true
Lenovo's is the official outfitter of
the Reuben report I want to put you in
this shirt go to bonobos calm answer
code TRR to zero for 20% off your first
purchase